Arby as a political spectacle it was
hard to beat pomp circumstance and
mutual admiration on the leader of the
most powerful country and a man who
wants to be a player on the world stage
but the relationship between Donald
Trump and India's Prime Minister
Narendra Modi is about more than just
compliments it's about trade money and
it's about China s perspective towards
India is based on location geography and
economic potential if you take all these
into account there's no other country in
Asia which can offer any kind of a
balance to China the United States sees
India as an essential buffer to the
growing expansionism of China in the
Asia region the US has the most powerful
Navy in the world but India is the
dominant power in the Indian Ocean and
there is concern that Beijing may spread
its power in the South China Sea to
India's area of control it sees itself
and it models itself on America on that
ability to project power across the
oceans to be a global player to have to
be able to influence outcomes and
distant shores and distant parts of the
world so to that extent China is almost
certainly going to expand its going to
foray into the Indian Ocean and the
Indian Navy will have to contend with
that more than 40% of the world's oil
passes through the Indian Ocean is the
lifeline for the economies of many
countries China has developed bases and
ports in East Africa and Sri Lanka it is
currently operating nine naval ships in
the Indian Ocean but there are concerns
this may increase India is an essential
early warning system with a string of
strategic listening posts in the region
India has just agreed to purchase three
billion dollars worth of attack
helicopters from the US but it's
military capability is far below that of
China which spends four times more on
defense in addition the Indian Navy is
in need of upgrading it has just two
aircraft carriers for example compared
to China's 10 and is scaling back plans
to expand its fleet because of costs for
India having a powerful friend like the
United States is important but it
doesn't want to make an enemy out of
China either the two countries fought a
order war in 1962 over disputed
territory and there are still unresolved
issues but India is well aware of the
strength and capability of Asia's
growing superpower too much of the
Indian public it seems the Indian Prime
Minister got more out of the Trump visit
but critics say it was simply kudos and
endorsement the real substance belongs
to the US with India having to tow an
American line that previous Indian
governments have resisted such as how it
deals with Iran the options are
shrinking because Trump is also making
it a world outside the Chinese influence
where it is unipolar you will if America
has a problem with Iran you will not
deal with Iran even the India of 20-30
years of a beaker far weaker
economically would have been able to
play the Russians against the Americans
and continue dealing with Iran they
can't do it today so they are they have
to face the Chinese threat and they then
have to do whatever America requires of
them and that is actually the current
situation in which we are operating
India is having to perform a delicate
balancing act but as the US and China
continue their battle for global
dominance its hoping it won't become
collateral damage Tony Berkeley al
Jazeera Delhi